اذا اراضي مطله على مزرعته في ساموخيا
التابعه لقريه رميش الحدوديه الصحابنا
العم نجيب
يتذكروك كيف كان طفلا يساعده والده في
الزراعه ليحرم من ارضه التي زرعت بالالغام
ابانا لاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مؤخرا فقط قامت قوات اليونيفيل بنزع
الالغام ليعتقد نجيب ان حلمه بالعوده الى
ارضه قد تحقق لكنه فوجئ بان جمعيه اخضر
بلا حدود التابعه لحزب الله قد نصبت خيمه
في ارضه ورغم ان الجمعيه تتدعي حرصها على
زرع الاشجار لكن الاهل يوفقوا عمليه
قطعتها قضيه اثارت مخاوف الاهل بان حزب
الله يسع لبناء مركز امنيه على اراضيهم
المطله على الحدود الاسرائيليه
على خريطه لا يمتلكها
من الجيش يتحمل مسؤوليه لانه هو دوره
المسيح حمايه الحدود وناحيه ما نوصل
حدودنا وعلى اراضينا
هيدي الارض كنا نزرعها بالخمس سنين بدنا
نرجع هلا نزرعه لانه كمان بده ينحط مركز
صيني ومركز سيليس هذا شيء ما بنقبل فيه
لانه نحن جميعا عايشين بسلام اتصلت بقوى
الامن الداخلي واتصلت بمخابرات الجيش
واساس وعدونا انه يحلوا هذه الامور
فقط من مقتل الجندي الايرلندي الذي وصل
الى لبنان لحفظ السلام لكنه يعود الى وطنه
في نعشان بعد ان اخترق الرصاص الاهالي
وكمال
اعتداءات الاهالي وتعدي الجمعيات البيئيه
يحذر مراقبون ان حزب الله يستخدم اساليب
متعدده لفرد السيطرهمته
اذا كانت اسرائيل
قوه دوليه او الدول تعرف اي تحقيق جد
حقيقي
الاهالي هي فكره مصطنعه ومفتعه من قبل حزب
الله وبالتالي كل ما يريده من هذا السلوك
وهذا الاسلوب بيقول انه انا لست وحدي
يتسلحوا اهالي رميش باوراق عثمانيه يعود
تاريخها الى اكثر من 150 عاما تثبت
ملكيتهم للاراضي يخشى هذه الماش ان تتحول
جمعيه اخضر بلا حدود الى ذريعه يستخدمه
حزب الله لفرد سيطرتها على الارض وان
يتحولوا وجود الحزب الى امر واقع في حاله
تجاهلت السلطهم غنويم العربيه رمش